la dernière fois que vous êtes venu à
l'heure de vérité monsieur de villiers
c'était le 22 mai on se demandait si
vous parviendriez à franchir le cap
fatidique des 5% de voix aux élections
européennes
vous avez dépassé les 12% et votre score
a été l'événement politique majeur du
seul scrutin national que nous ayons
connue en 1994
la question qui se pose aujourd'hui à
six mois de l'élection présidentielle et
la suivante
qu'allez vous faire de cette confiance
que vous accorde le tiers des électeurs
de la majorité le résultat de mai
prochain est très largement entre vos
mains qui soutiendrez-vous et serez vous
vous même candidat alors vous avez
coutume de vaud en tirer par une boutade
en citant richelieu il faut gagner la
rive comme les rameurs en lui tournant
le dos mais on peut pas éternellement
contempler le chemin parcouru il arrive
un moment où il faut dire en quel point
on veut accosté alors ce moment est
semble-t-il venu monsieur de villiers
est il pensable que la petite moitié des
électeurs français qui ont voté contre
le traité de maastricht n'est le choix
en avril prochain contre monsieur le pen
et monsieur robert hue
alors nous allons diviser cette émission
en trois parties en commençant par ce
qui intéresse le plus directement les
français les perspectives de lutte
contre le chômage le gouvernement de
monsieur balladur ci prend t'il bien la
semaine dernière à votre place monsieur
giraud qui est le ministre du travail
promettait deux cent mille chômeurs de
moins dans un an
le gouvernement mise sur la reprise de
l'activité pour résoudre le problème et
tous les discours ministériels
contiennent ce mot magique de reprise
la reprise est là tout va changer est ce
que c'est votre analyse et bien vous le
dirai à christine clerc du figaro
magazine qui vous interrogera sur
l'ensemble du bilan de monsieur balladur
puis nous parlerons avec jean marie
colombani de la vie politique en france
et plus particulièrement du spectacle
assez affligeant qu'offre actuellement
la majorité au pouvoir votre majorité
avec sa guerre des chefs et ses échanges
de lettres aigre-douce monsieur balladur
ne l'est plus seulement contre le
chômage et du faut aussi se battre
contre la corruption qui mine moralement
gouvernement et contre les divisions
internes de la majorité le tout dans un
climat de cohabitation avec le président
de la république qui virent un petit peu
à l'acide
enfin nous terminerons l'émission avec
alain duhamel qui nous entraînement sur
le terrain international le parlons bien
sûr la construction de l'europe et des
perspectives nouvelles qui s'ouvrent
après la réélection du chancelier kohl
l'europe les risques de dissolution de
notre souveraineté nationale
les ravages du libre échange ce sont là
des thèmes sur lesquels vous vous
démarquer du reste de la majorité mais
faites vous encore vraiment partie de la
majorité on va voir ça avec christine
clerc qui va vous parler du bilan du
gouvernement avec laquelle vous allez
parler vous du bilan du gouvernement
le teamplay si vous n'êtes que j'ai ici
c'est un florilège de vos déclarations
de vaud méchanceté contre vos amis de la
droite
ça va de léotard à qui j'ai prêté un
livre là ne l'a toujours pas colorier
jusqu'à nous vivons un juin 40 mental
avec monsieur balladur en passant par je
quitte ce parti d'incarcérer d'un
carcéral
alors ma question est celle-ci est-ce
que vous appartenait toujours à cette
majorité au nom de laquelle vous êtes
fait élire sur la liste européenne ce
avait cassé un clair les gens qui ont le
sens de la formule
comme c'est votre cas en tant que
journaliste on le rend près de beaucoup
si j'avais géré le florilège
si j'avais le florilège de tous et de
toutes vos méchancetés sur les hommes
politiques
je serai un amateur par rapport à une
professionnelle non slave je réponds à
votre question je réponds aux questions
mais je suis dans la majorité bien
évidemment la majorité elle a été élue
en mars 93
je les fais gagner j'ai contribué à la
faire gagner
et s'il ya une liste et une aussi grande
victoire c'est parce qu'il ya des gens
qui se sont battus pour que le discrédit
moral qui frappait les socialistes
soient pris en compte par les électeurs
et le 12 juin dernier que s'est il passé
il y avait deux listes en présence dans
la majorité tout le monde l'a dit tout
le monde l'a vu tout le monde l'a
constaté est d'ailleurs le ministre de
l'intérieur charles pasqua au soir du 12
juin lorsqu'il a donné des résultats a
été très clair il a additionné les voix
des deux listes de la majorité et qu'est
ce qu'a fait le premier ministre
il a additionné les voix des délices de
la maison qui appartient encore à cette
majorité oui mais ce qui est vrai c'est
que la majorité
aujourd'hui elle est très diverse et là
par exemple sur la question de l'europe
de la souveraineté de la france sur la
question du libre échangisme mondial et
sur d'autres questions d'ailleurs des
des sensibilités différentes
moi ce que je veux c'est être
l'aiguillon de la majorité le coeur
battant de la majorité je l'étais au
moment des élections européennes
fidèle au combat que nous avions mené
avec philippe séguin et charles pasqua
moment de maastricht
je poursuis cette action alors qu'est ce
que vous pensez du gouvernement qui est
le vôtre qui essai nucléaire j'ai cité
le juin 40 mental alors est ce que est
ce que c'est balladur le juin 40 mentale
puisque vous dites que nous vivons
actuellement est ce que vous pensez
comme quelqu'un qu'il s'agit d'un
moniteur de ski des gestes propres
formules les autant de leur contexte
monsieur balladur a du flegme du sang
froid
il est incontestablement un homme d'état
comme d'ailleurs monsieur chirac comme
monsieur giscard d'estaing et les autres
moi j'ai les meilleures relations
aujourd'hui les autres monsieur bart
vraiment si d autres tubas j'en oublie
ce sont des gens qui sont des hommes des
six mois je n'ai pas de contentieux avec
simplement je suis profondément
profondément navré par par le spectacle
qui a été donné par la majorité cette
semaine la guerre des bristols et ayant
le plus profond respect pour les grands
leaders
je me dis parfois et je crains que il
n'en vienne à incarner aux yeux de
beaucoup de français par une sorte de
fatalité la génération de la défaite
mais quand je vous ai pu abandonner
leurs attaques
c'était bien de l'intention de qui était
contenu dans ma question d hier quand je
vous parlais du gouvernement balladur ya
une chose qui m'étonne puisque non
seulement je vous écoute mais je vous
lis j'ai lu votre livre la société de
connivences je lisais à dire en même
temps que celui d'alain madelin votre
ancien camarade de la bande à léo le
ciel commence sur l'injustice sociale
c'est un mot qui ne vient jamais dans
votre lit ni à justice ni justice ni
exclu ni coeur d'ailleurs vous êtes mal
informé parce que vous savez ce que je
viens de faire cette la reine et
revendre et abaisserait pour votre
question parce que c'est une question
qui est en même temps une assignation
comme si le contrat de la gauche qu'on
appelle la droite était absolument
insensible à la justice sociale c'est ce
que vient de faire avant d c'est une
grande première en france
on a décidé de prendre en compte le rmi
il ya 5000 rmistes amendée et de
proposer aux rmistes une immersion en
entreprise est de transformer le contrat
de rmi j'espère que des lois et les
règlements ne l'empêcheront pas en
contrat d'entreprise c'est à dire ça
coûte pas plus d'argent à l'état pas
plus d'argent collectivités pas plus
d'argent rmistes ça ne retire pas
d'argent mais ça leur permet d'avoir un
véritable contrat de travail
alors vous savez sont pas ceux qui qui
écrit exclusion exclusion ou social
social qui en font le plus sur le
terrain moi je me sens tant que
président d'un conseil général tout à
fait comptable de toute la misère qui
existe dans notre société et je vais
plus loin
j'essaye de comprendre pourquoi il ya
cette misère je crois qu'ils ont fait
vous faites la société que j'ai appelé
cette connivence
un teckel médiatico-politique une erreur
de diagnostic qui est aussi grave et que
tu un poison aussi mortel que l'a été le
socialisme à une certaine époque c'est
le libre échangisme mondial qui pousse
aujourd'hui toutes frontières ouvertes
je parle de l'europe
toutes nos entreprises les unes après
les autres à aller à la rencontre des
salaires les plus bas à s'installer à
calcutta à bombay en corée du sud ou en
chine
parce que dans la grande concurrence
mondiale nous sommes le gat est en train
d'établir un marché commun mondial de
l'emploi
et tant qu'on ne fera pas la préférence
communautaire on aura beau multiplier
les réformes et monsieur balladur six
essais avec talent on remplira assauts
percée voulait dire que c'est la seule
chose à faire c'est la première fois je
me suis pour une stratégie japonaise de
l'emploi en france
qu'est ce que c'est une stratégie
japonaise de l'emploi en france vous
faire ce qu'ils ont fait la protection
et la conquête mais vous ne pouvez pas
conquérir
si vous n'avez pas d'abord la protection
c'est bien que des gens comme alain
madelin rouvre ce débat mais il faut pas
oublier la protection si vous n'avez pas
la protection la conquête ne servira à
rien il nous faut aujourd'hui si on veut
multiplier les emplois multiplier les
entreprises mais complètement renverser
notre perspective qu'est ce que ça veut
dire renverser notre perspective
ça veut dire l'homme plutôt que la
monnaie
quand on voit ce que sont et ont intérêt
on a privilégié la monnaie ça veut dire
l'entreprise plutôt que la technocratie
dépensière regardez le budget de l'état
aujourd'hui les charges
extraordinairement lourd de la masse
salariale de l'état
ça veut dire l'investisseur plutôt que
le rentier ça veut dire le référentiel
du notaire plutôt que le livre giscard
d'estaing pour l'abaissement des charges
sociales oui je crois qu'il a mis le
doigt
sur un problème réel mais ce n'est pas
suffisant je reviens à la question de
l'exclusion si on veut aujourd'hui
résoudre le problème de l'exclusion
il faut faire trois choses simples
premièrement c'est vrai baisser les
charges sur les salaires les plus bas
mais deuxièmement est d'abord protéger
les emplois qui sont les plus menacés
c'est à dire les emplois qui concerne la
main d'oeuvre la moins qualifiés qui est
aujourd'hui en butte à cette concurrence
sauvage des pays à bas salaires
arguments très forts vous avez séduit
beaucoup de gens aux élections
européennes avec cet argument j'ai
rencontré hier des gens qui avaient voté
pour vous aux élections européennes et
qui m'ont dit mais je ne voterai pas
pour lui à des élections législatives ni
présidentielle parce que je ne suis pas
du tout d'accord avec sa vision de la
société française
alors j'aimerais qu'on y vienne un peu
premier point d'actualité récente vous
êtes prononcée contre le port du voile
il foulard islamique à l'école
et vous dites il faut que les il faut
que les musulmans s'adapte à la société
française mais à quelle société
française voulez vous qu'ils s'adaptent
est ce que c'est une société laïque sans
crucifix sans signe extérieur de
chrétienté ou est ce que c'est une
société chrétienne
attention si on vous suivez on
considérait que les sapins de noël sont
des signes ostentatoires qu'il faudra
les supprimer donc le signe clair c'est
très simple c'est très simple je pense
comme charles pasqua comme il l'a dit
récemment ya quelques heures
et comme françois bayrou dans sa
circulaire qui est excellente
encore qu'ils épluchent désigné plus
directement le voile islamique
puisqu'ils se déduit il s'agit que s'il
doit y avoir un islam en france quatre
millions de musulmans
cet islam doit respecter nos modes de
vie nos coutumes notre tradition y
compris notre tradition judéo chrétienne
dont je ne rougis par qui fait partie du
principe de la et de la laïcité
rendez à césar ce qui est à césar et à
dieu ce qui est à dieu c'est là la
source du principe de laïcité
qu'est ce que ça veut dire la laïcité
c'est pas le laïcisme laïcité ça veut
pas dire qu'on va interdire toute
religion france que pour pour un point
catholique un chrétien juif ou un
musulman
ce serait une société totalitaire les
signes et la lie
et ça veut dire la neutralité ça veut
dire la conciliation nécessaire et qui
n'est pas facile entre la pratique de la
foi et le nécessaire respect de nos
institutions et de nos valeurs ça veut
dire que on refuse une société
multiculturelle en france est-ce qu'il
faut accepter la création d'écoles
musulmanes
s'il respectait par exemple tous les
critères ils sont les recruteurs des
contrats de solesmes jérusalem pour la
liberté totale de création des écoles de
gestion des écoles vous reprocher la
liberté à la condition comme pour les
mosquées
regardez ce qui s'est passé avec la
mosquée de lyon à la condition que ya
pas de financements d'état étrangers ce
qui est le cas actuellement
la mosquée de lyon a été financée par
l'arabie saoudite
ça ça me paraît grave à la condition que
les responsables dans le queyras et
imane l'imam de la mosquée de lyon il
est algérien l'imam de la mosquée de
paris sauf erreur de ma part il est
algérien
ce n'est pas normal moi je ne
l'acceptent pas l'islam de france
s'il doit y avoir un islam de france et
moi je respecte beaucoup les musulmans
et j'ai beaucoup d'amis musulmans il
faut pas confondre les musulmans et les
islamistes et bien doit accepter ce que
nous sommes ce que notre histoire
ce qu'est notre patrimoine spirituel
moral culturel c'est aussi simple que ça
je veux pas pourquoi ça vous étonne
voilà ma position à l'est des choix
c'est la position du bon sens alors
autre question vous définissez parfois
comme un charbonnier du pape
la citation n'est pas fausse cette fois
le pape continue à lutter non seulement
contre l'avortement mais contre la
contraception alors vous qui êtes
favorable je crois au rétablissement de
la peine de mort est ce que vous êtes
toujours contre l'avortement et contre
la contraception
je m'attendais à ce genre de salmigondis
responsable parce que à chaque fois que
je viens à l'heure de vérité c'était
c'était monsieur leva et qui tenait le
rôle de bessines d'avec les stimuler à
la dernière fois je voulais qu'on me
changer la lamal gamme
bonjour de cette prolongation par
question c'est une question de choix
personnel il ya des gens qui pratiquent
une religion en france d'autres qui ont
plus de recul et de scepticisme nous
sommes la france
moi je n'impose pas mes choix personnels
même si j'ai de l'admiration pour pour
le pape jean paul ii et je voudrais
simplement vous dire que le principe de
la tolérance
c'est ce qu'ils permettent d'accepter
qu'on puisse vivre tous ensemble alors
dans les questions je vais poser des
questions de choix personnel par exemple
le ici sur ce plateau de l'heure de
vérité
si vous interrogez les gens qui sont là
sur la question de la peine de mort par
exemple on a qui sont pas d'accord moi
le juge jean pierre qui était un ami
très proche de moi sur la question de la
peine de mort on en a parlé cette
semaine il pas d'accord avec moi moi je
considère que c'est votre colis sied
aussi il faut rappeler pour moi c'est
pas une religion la question à peine de
mort c'est simplement il faut au sommet
de l'échelle des peines une peine
symbolique qui soit juste et dissuasive
souvenez-vous de christian van ginhoven
cet assassin qui avait assassiné deux
petites filles
muriel et ingrid et quand le juge
d'instruction a voulu faire la
reconstitution et je le dis avec
l'émotion du père de famille il n'a pas
pu continuer parce qu'il s'est mis à
pleurer et je trouve qu'aujourd'hui à la
société n'est plus protégé alors peine
demain ou pas peine de mort c'est pas le
problème le problème c'est qu'il faut
que les français aient le sentiment que
l'état les protège c'est tout c'est tout
dire ici à l'avortement et la
contraception sur sur l'avortement
le veer est ce que vous seriez le pape
est ce que vous vous seriez pourquoi
annuler la loi de l'interruption de
grossesse et j'ai déjà répondu à l'heure
de vérité sur cette question en disant
que je ne souhaitais pas pour ma part la
contrainte
je souhaite que l'on mette en place en
france au niveau national et au niveau
local
toutes les alternatives matérielle et
affective pour qu'on empêche ce qu est
un drame ce qui est une détresse une
détresse pour la femme une détresse pour
l'enfant et une détresse pour toute la
société
les voiliers et christine clerc malgré
toute l'admiration que j'ai pour la
journaliste que vous êtes entre vos
mains sur ce sujet là où bien sûr le
sujet du droit à la vie
et le pape ait choisi le pape
on a envie merci juste une question vous
avez toujours une médaille de la vierge
sur vous oui jeté sur moi toujours bien
merci
christine clerc on va passer maintenant
jean marie colombani mais je regrette
qu'on ne soit pas allé assez loin sur le
terrain de l'emploi
est-ce que non mademoiselle mademoiselle
capable d'arrêter de payer vos ministres
et les députés pour qu'enfin il ya une
morale pour que les gens travaillent
bénévolement
merci de proposer la place merci sur
question je sais pas c'est réalisable et
non pas elle est venue avec vous
j'espère qu'on va parler parce que la
question que je pose ma dame cdu c'est
la question clé veut dire est ce que
j'endure jean de villiers non peut-être
peut-être est-elle venue avec vous alors
pour le coup et je préfère vous pas mais
je préfère vous poser des questions et
puis on y reviendra à maka si vous êtes
d'accord
jean bassères on va faire un peu de
politique avant que vous ne reveniez au
sujet de fond avec alain sur l'europe
notamment
puisque nous sommes à six mois très
exactement de l'élection présidentielle
du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle jour pour jour
aujourd'hui donc la question que je vous
pose et qui est naturellement très
attendue est de savoir si vous-même
serait candidat à l'élection
présidentielle je je ne l'exclus pas ce
n'était pas ce n'est pas mon hypothèse
de départ moi je veux faire gagner la
majorité et faire gagner la france et je
considère aujourd'hui que nous sommes
effectivement avec une véritable machine
à perdre qui s'est mise en route en
avril 1993 avec le début de la
colonisation avant de voir jouer avant
de voir pour moi les choses qui sont il
réduit à deux voies avant de voir
comment cette machine à perdre vous
conter la transformer en machine à
gagner
je voudrais savoir pourquoi vous
n'excluez pas vous même de vous porter
sur sur ce front la rennaise les volets
du fait que l'idée la plus répandue est
que
mieux vaudrait pour la majorité un seul
candidat pour moi les deux questions
essentielles delà du débat présidentiel
sont les suivantes la souveraineté est
le problème du libre échangisme mondial
le gat la souveraineté puisque le
prochain septennat sera le septennat
d'un nouveau pacte fondateur européen
strict c'est fini il va y avoir en 1996
un nouveau traité est-ce que vous
viendrez sur le fond de cette question
avec alala de l'erreur tout le meilleur
d'eux se rate souvent très blanches de
la question c'est de savoir si la france
va disparaître si on accepte qu'elle
disparaisse par exemple dans un noyau
dur franco allemand ou si la france va à
la reconquête de sa souveraineté en
faisant une autre europe et par l'europe
du passé mais que l'europe de l'avenir
ça c'est une question déterminante ou
quoi c'est une question déterminante
parce que la france va présider le
conseil des ministres et que notre
adversaire c'est jacques delors restons
sur le terrain deuxième erreur la caisse
de l'élite je livre ici on y va y avoir
une nouvelle donne économique mondiale
si les pays qui ont signé le gars tu
décides de ratifier le gat ce n'est pas
le cas pour l'instant il ya 25 pays sur
125 et l'ont ratifié et s'il ya la
ratification du gade c'est l'acte le
plus important du monde moderne depuis
la guerre et ce sera une hémorragie de
nos emplois qui continuera bon ça disons
c'est le
les principes que vous allez poser dans
la négociation sur la présidentielle moi
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de savoir en
termes politiques simplement de
conditions politiques
vous avez employé vous même le mot de
machine à perdre comment est-ce que vous
la voyez cette machine à perdre se
transformer en machine à gagner
et quelle part allez vous y prendre est
ce que cette part vous conduire à
vous-même rendre garder une part de la
bataille ou non à la machine à perdre
chez nous à droite et puis à la machine
à remonter le temps à gauche avec le
pacte avec le programme commun
reconstituer cette semaine entre
monsieur évaluer et monsieur a eu c'est
quand même incroyable
moi je trouve ce jeu propose deux de
remiser la machine à perdre chez un
brocanteur et de la remplacer par une
mécanique de la victoire une mécanique
de la victoire pour la france et que
reposerait sur trois au hb essentiel
premièrement une autre politique
européenne que la politique de monsieur
de l'or une autre politique de l'emploi
que la politique menée depuis 12 ans
avec un véritable renversement de
perspective et une autre politique de la
moralisation public c'est à dire un
pacte de probité publique
j'espère qu'on va venir chacun sait pas
noté l'an dernier si sur chacun de ces
points je n'ai pas le sentiment que mes
idées que ces idées là que j'ai défendu
le 12 juin que nous avons défendues avec
charles pasqua et philippe séguin moment
de maastricht et qui sont les conditions
d'un sursaut pour notre pays si j'ai le
sentiment que ces idées là ne sont pas
prises en compte par le ou les autres
candidats alors selon vous saouler des
gendres aime moi mais vous serez
candidat mais il est évident que la
solution raisonnable aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il y est un seul candidat avec un
programme fort aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'on voit on voit plusieurs candidats
officieux mais qui sont déjà des
candidats monsieur chirac et monsieur
balladur
il n'y a pas de programme et a pas de
programme fort et moi je souhaite qu'ils
aient d'abord un programme fort on verra
les vous il est bien conscient mais mais
vous voyez croyez que les conditions que
vous posez pour ne pas être candidats
seront remplies oui j'y crois
pour deux raisons
regardez quand monsieur baudis comment
il a été obligé de déportés sa campagne
quand il a fait ce qu'on a appelé la
mesure où fédéraliste il était il est
parti fédéraliste il est arrivé à la fin
hostiles au fédéralisme
donc je crois à la grâce monsieur de
virieu bombay et puis je pense est en
baisse à la grâce est en face de nous on
a raté expression parce que ça me fait
penser à jacques delors est ce qu'il ya
une chose qui est extraordinaire en ce
moment on ne parle jamais du candidat
qui sont en face de nous monsieur
jacques de leurs on aura monsieur
jacques d'heure monsieur jacques delors
les milliards des culs lui traverse les
doigts comme de l'eau soleil monsieur
jacques delors qui est un excellent
démissionnaire et un exécrable
gestionnaire il a dévalué trois fois
moins d'un an quand il était mise
l'économie et des finances au plus beau
temps du socialisme triomphant 81 et il
a démissionné trois fois il est allé
porter trois fois sa démission jean
françois mitterrand se fait alors ce
fait dix ans où ira-t-il apporter sa
démission ça fait dix ans qu'il ira
danser sa démission à monsieur paul
ça fait bizarre ça fait dix ans celle de
la ve vous reprenez le vieux enfin vous
engager sur le vieux terrain-là du parti
de l'étranger en parlant d'un
rapprochant comme ça jacques delors de
monsieur a pas du tout je crois que
monsieur de l'heure et ariane 5 cette
page vous vous souhaitiez élever le
débat je suis pas sûr que vous en
preniez le cheval non je crois que
monsieur de leurs six j'élève le débat
j'élève le débat parce que je considère
que monsieur de leurs à une conception
de l'europe technocratique sur
centralisée antidémocratique et que
monsieur heures son comportement est un
comportement qui se détournent des
intérêts de la fin revenant sur lequel
il est écrit notizai revenons sur le
parana par la cee aux animaux darcis
chrétienne arrive parce que vous
vous encore une fois vous réalisez que
vous allez développer avec alain tout à
l'heure vous êtes bien conscient que si
ces conditions ne sont pas remplies et
si donc comme tout le laisse penser vous
êtes candidat à l'élection
présidentielle on va vous accusez de
prendre votre part au contraire à la
reconstruction de cette machine à perdre
comment les bourreaux de résoudre cette
contradiction
monsieur colombani je n'ai pas pris ma
décision j'attends de voir les candidats
il ya des candidats virtuels attendons
que ce soit des candidats réel mais
attendons de voir leur programme
je ne désespère pas que leurs programmes
soient fondées sur le sursaut du bon
sens sur les questions que j'aborde et
qui sont les questions de l'emploi il y
aura pas d'autre dira pas de salut sur
l'emploi sion même si on ne fait pas la
préférence communautaire sur les
questions de souveraineté et sur la
question de la moralité publique
vous savez pour le reste l'homme marié
dans la machine à perdre j'y reviens à
l'instant parce que quand j'étais venu à
l'heure de vérité il ya quelques temps
le 22 mai oui mais avant avant j'étais
venu on avait parlé de la cohabitation
et je me souviendrai souvent je me
souviens que monsieur duhamel m'avait
dit d'ailleurs justement
vous êtes tout seul à vous battre contre
la cohabitation alors comment pouvez
vous avoir raison tout ça le
sous-entendu oui on était quelques-uns
avec alain griotteray avec quelques
parlementaires qui sont ici ce matin à
dire attention cohabitation casse-cou
pourquoi parce que la cohabitation ce
sera une période d'attentisme pré
présidentielle et ce sera une période de
connivence pour la politique extérieure
et la politique européenne en est dedans
en la machine à perdre
faut pas nous en parler il faut pas en
parler à moi je vais en parler à ceux
qui stratégiquement ont commis à ce
moment là une erreur qui comprend pas
alors une erreur qui peut nous être
fatal
il faut aller vite la poste et il savait
tiens je l'aperçois mon ami jean
montaldo cité jean montaldo jean
montaldo il faut vous parler d'eux
de lui pas de jacques delorme et
forcioli terrain et jean montaldo
m'avait dit il ya un proverbe africain
qui est le suivant pour la cohabitation
ne fait jamais ta litière ne fait jamais
ton lit dans la litière du lion il te
mangerais bon il ya le temps passe là on
va pas avoir le temps de tout abordé
vous savez que ce qu on dit généralement
de l'élection présidentielle c'est
qu'elle se gagne au centre vous vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec ce point de vue
largement à savoir pourquoi si elle se
gagne pas au centre ce qu elle se gagne
à droite et si elle se gagne à droite
est ce qu'elle se gagnant avec les
électeurs de jean-marie le pen
et de ce point de vue là j'aimerais
savoir quels sont vos relations avec les
valeurs que défend jean marie le pen ce
que l'on manie je remercie de me poser
cette question qui va me permettre une
fois pour toutes de bien mettre les
choses au clair
je suis dans la majorité je me bats pour
la majorité sur le pen est à l'extérieur
de la majorité se bat contre la majorité
je ne me situe pas par rapport aux idées
de monsieur le pen sur la france sur
maastricht sur le combat contre la
corruption sur le gat sur le combat pour
les valeurs se situent pas par rapport à
monsieur jean marie le pen et je
regrette qui est actuellement dans une
certaine presse dont votre journal le
monde il ya trois jours sous votre plume
dans le journal régional ouest france
d'hier des amalgames qui sont qui sont
qui me paraissent inexactes tout à fait
infondé suffit de regarder les sondages
sortie des urnes du 12 juin pour voir
que les gens qui ont voté pour moi c'est
l'électorat de la majorité et je
regrette que ce soit une manière
détournée moyenne sur colombani pour
dire au fond philippe de villiers c'est
l'extrême droite ce coup là bas ni je
vais vous dire quelque chose en
regardant bien les yeux avec tout mon
coeur est avec beaucoup de sérénité tout
mon patrimoine familial morale
personnelle
tout ce que j'ai reçue en héritage et
tout ce que je transmets mes enfants
fils d'un combattant volontaire de la
résistance avec mes amis qui sont ici
comme un griot trek a été un des
premiers héros de la résistance la
génération d'estienne d'orves tout se
révoltent en moins contre les sentiments
de racisme d'antisémitisme
tous et des xénophobes btu ne trouverait
jamais chez moi un mot qui puisse
rappeler ses sentiments à braga alors
j'en ai marre monsieur colombani jodie
aux téléspectateurs j'en ai marre de
cette assimilation de cette déformation
de cette désinformation de cette
diabolisation la presse aujourd'hui est
tellement loin du forum des idées
tellement réductrice la classe politique
elle-même a tellement tendance à mettre
les gens catégories qui sont des
caricatures que je souhaiterais qu'on
est là vraiment le débat et qu'on
regarde quelles sont les valeurs
aujourd'hui qui sont les valeurs de
survie de la france qui sont des valeurs
transversale moi je ne suis retrouvé
dans ce combat avec des gens comme
thierry jean-pierre et d'une sensibilité
de gauche avec d'autres gens ici comme
antoine gaudino qu'ils ont une
sensibilité de gauche et nous
considérons aujourd'hui que par delà nos
désaccords sur des valeurs qui sont
essentiels il yad'autres valeurs
essentielles et qui sont des valeurs
transversale qui sont les valeurs de la
survie la gauche la droite on en a marre
la valeurs de probité
cette droite cette gauche là valeur de
souveraineté cette droite cette gauche
le combat sur le libre échangisme
mondial pendant deux mois je suis contre
les centrales nucléaires est ce que je
suis pour sa écologistes de gauche
qu'est ce que ça veut dire tout ça ça
n'a plus aucun sens regardons la france
de l'an 2000 par la france visent à
evian va sans doute c'est comme toujours
on vous jugera aux actes et aux
comportements
juste un mot encore on vous prête le
plus qu'aux déclarations on vous prête
l'intention d'élargir votre mouvement de
créer un nouveau mouvement politique
alors j'aurai savoir à quoi ça va
ressembler à quoi ça va servir et qui va
le payer
qui va le financer puisque on va parler
ensuite du financement de la vie
publique
joyeusement à la première manche
commence pas à la question sera financé
par les cotisations et des dons dans le
cadre des lois de 88 et 90 est inutile
de vous rappeler comment très
précisément pour une personne physique
inde on ne peut pas aller au delà de 50
mille francs et pour une personne morale
cinq cent mille francs il faut savoir
que le budget de combat pour les valeurs
le mouvement combat pour les valeurs que
j'ai créée en 1991 d'un budget annuel
qui est très inférieur à 3 millions de
francs très inférieur à 3 millions de
francs
à quoi servira-t-il ce mouvement il
s'appellera le mouvement pour la france
eh bien il servira à faire gagner à la
majorité il sera
une des composantes j'en ai parlé avec
que jacques chirac avec edouard balladur
avec valéry giscard d'estaing une des
composantes essentielles avec l'udf et
leur père de la future majorité
présidentielle il sera stimulant il sera
un coeur battant et il proposera tout
simplement
premièrement de ne pas laisser nos
adversaires tranquille parce qu'encore
une fois actuellement la majorité se
préoccupe pas du tout nos adversaires on
n'en parle pas c'est quand même
incroyable on parle de corruption et
appliquent ou encore et peut-être ce
soir sur tf1 il va lui faire une leçon
d'éthique et deuxièmement et
deuxièmement de ce qu'on propose c'est
simple sortir la france du socialisme et
apporter aux français les grandes
libertés la liberté d'aller et venir
il n'est plus garantie aujourd'hui en
france la liberté de la france la
liberté des familles la liberté de
l'école la liberté des créateurs en
faisant baisser les prélèvements
obligatoires qu'elle ajuste ram
parce que ce sera malheureusement le
temps est compté je verrai juste le
temps de poser une dernière question
dans votre entourage et dans votre
dispositif il ya un homme de poids qui
est jimmy goldsmith
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas gêné par le
fait que la fortune de jimmy goldsmith
doit une part à la spéculation que sa
fortune a été transférée d'europe vers
les pays les plus lointains et d'une
certaine façon pour bâtir et père et
perpétuer sa fortune il est allé comme
vous le disiez tout à l'heure à la
rencontre des salaires les plus bas
est-ce que malgré tout ça ne vous gêne
pas est-ce que sa valeur est ce qu'il
vous apporte les avantages tout ça
monsieur colombani ce que ça vous gêne
d'insulter les gens non je n'insulte pas
je n'ai donc non je pose la question et
on en haut mais je pose une vraie
question et en écoutant on entendait
dire des chaussures sont maintenant
répondait et répondait là devenez
partenaire c'est que c'est pas comme ça
qu'on t'a le journaliste politique s'en
mêle
bien n'avez pas le droit de dire une
chose comme ça monsieur jimmy goldsmith
c'est vrai il est riche il a fait
fortune en france il faut sans l'excuser
il a fait fortune comme un grand chef
d'entreprise comme accords d'entreprise
fortune aujourd'hui est alors de rentrer
plus tôt en europe mille emplois et
quand il a pris sa retraite de ces
entreprises en 1987 il ne doit rien à
l'état lui ni à personne
il a décidé de mener un autre combat
qu'elle combat des idées en créant la
fondation goldsmith pour l'environnement
il se bat en mettant son argent sa
fortune à la disposition des grandes
causes qu'il défend est notamment la
cause de la lutte contre le libre
échangisme mondial sait à quoi il a
passé son été jimmy goldsmith
il pourrait très bien être en retraite
tranquillement tout l'argent qu'il a il
pourrait le faire
il était aux états unis pour convaincre
les sénateurs du congrès américain pour
repousser vous le mot l'éradication la
ratification du gamin a répondu sur le
fond
donc monsieur jimmy goldsmith qui était
numéro 2 sur ma liste est un homme
d'honneur un homme d'idées un précurseur
avec maurice allais il a été le premier
grand chef d'entreprise et sa note a
posé le problème de libre échange et
cécilia jean marie colombani on n'ira
pas plus loin ce que sur la carte
monsieur paul suite n'est pas là
aujourd'hui
william smith il est à la bbc à faire la
même émission que nous donc en anglais
pour fer continue entre les anglais de
du problème de libre échangisme mondial
et de la nécessité de ne pas signer le
gat allongeant mais cette vidéo français
en français alors d'abord vous vous êtes
plein
que vos prises de position ou que vous
même soyez dites-vous souvent diabolisé
par vos adversaires ou par la presse est
ce que vous n'avez pas le sentiment que
vous même et vous arrive assez souvent
de diaboliser vos adversaires et leurs
prises de position oui mais quand je
vous pose une sérieuse bonne question
merci toujours merci merci on continue
toujours courtoise absolument on
continue mais vous n'avez pas le
sentiment parfois vous le matin sur
europe 1 2 mais gratiné un peu plus
qu'il n'en faut qu'il nous faut sûrement
pas puisque c'est ce que j'allais pas
plus que les auront pas puisque les
assurés ne tombait pas grands parce que
les hommes par len purificateur du
bocage
non non non je sais pas vous non j'ai
pas moi bon alors ça pour ça alors mais
vous le fait avec talent donc je moi je
parle d'un énorme talent à l'erreur pour
l art est d'abord un ce qui vous arrive
de diaboliser vos adversaires
sincèrement diaboliser ces prises de
position c'est peut-être pas le mot qui
convient par rapport aux qualités que me
faisait christine clay a annoncé ma
question parce que claudine clé mais
c'est la vie de monsieur de l'or tout
moi j'essaye de
ne pas me tromper l'adversaire mais
depuis je suis dans le combat politique
moi les combats dans lequel je me suis
lancé regarder la corruption première
fois que je suis venu parler de la
corruption à la télévision avec
l'inspecteur godinot c'était avec vous
m'aviez même dit à ce moment-là vous
trouvez pas que le mot est trop fort la
corruption 1990 sur maastricht duprat
l'impression de m'être trompé sur le
gâteau me suis pas trompé quand j'avais
dit à i lfaut voilà on nous avait dit
faut signer le gâteau avant le 15
décembre dans tellement trompé sur la
cohabitation non plus et aujourd'hui je
constate que sur les sujets que nous
abordons avec la présidentielle pour
l'instant je me suis pas ton temps et
donc vous avez toujours raison c'est non
c'est pas ça ce qui compte c'est le
débat d idées vont façonner leur sur les
adversaires alors la semaine dernière
dimanche dernier c'est vrai je reconnais
je suis un adversaire
enfin tout à fait résolus delà de la
gauche ça c'est vrai la semaine dernière
les allemands aux élections législatives
générales ont reconduit avec une courte
majorité mais reconduit helmut kohl est
ce que c'est un résultat d'abord qui
vous a fait plaisir qui vous a ennuyé
qui m'a fait plaisir
alors pourquoi parce que helmut kohl est
un homme d'état un des grands hommes
d'état de cette fin de siècle qui a su
dans son pays réduire l'extrême gauche
et réduire les saints droite parce que
précisément il a pris en compte les
grands problèmes politiques
d'assainissement budgétaire
d'assainissement financier
d'assainissement et communistes ont
quand même fait un assez bon score je
sais pas ce que alors dans ce cas là si
vous lancez des choristes ont fait un
bon score d'allemagne de l'est a4
condamin de l'ess ne l'ont conduit au
total beaucoup plus que ça holman de la
bande annonce ici vous dites ils ont
fait près de 20% au mot le score de 12
1% des européennes alors c'est
mirobolants escale à séoul copains n'ont
en tout cas alors il les small et il
donne c'est bien ou c'est pas bien pour
nous alors c'est bien pour l'allemagne
arbon mais pour la france
maintenant dans le document de la cdo il
ya une chose qui m'a frappé l'enseignant
faut dire qu'ils sont partis le parti de
monsieur collet que monsieur ghosn n'a
pas démenti chaque chapitre commence par
il est de l'intérêt de l'allemagne 2
alors moi je me pose la même question il
est de l'intérêt de la france de quoi de
quoi et bien moi je dis que
ce que nous propose aujourd'hui
allemagne il ne faut pas l'accepter
alors pour une fois pas accepter pour
nos auditeurs il faut peut-être rappeler
que l'idée force elle qui a suscité le
plus grand débat dans le temps le
document des chrétiens démocrates à
celle qui a suscité le plus grand débat
c'est leur idée d'un noyau dur qui
serait composé distille de la france de
l'allemagne du benelux et de ceux qui
pourraient ensuite ses seins s'y rallier
et qui essaieraient de faire avancer les
politiques communes européennes là où
c'est possible voilà alors votre
réaction
alors moi j'ai très attachés à l'amitié
franco allemande et mais je voudrais pas
qu'elle soit finalement mises à mal par
une europe qui serait déséquilibré alors
pourquoi je suis contre ce projet
d'abord parce que la france elle sa
position géographique et historique
c'est pas la même la france ne doit pas
oublier qu'elle est aussi une puissance
méditerranéenne qu'elle est une
puissance atlantique a tiré vers le
grand large et que ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en pologne en russie la
regarde elle a des liens là bas donc
c'est pas simplement le couple
franco-allemand même si le couple
franco-allemand c'est pour nous très
important et puis on se dire qu'on y
attacher trop d'importance
non je dirais que non non mais il ne
faut pas
dire qu'il ya une sorte d'alternative
d'un côté le couple franco-allemand qui
serait notre seul avenir
et puis le reste qu'on abandonnerait je
crois que la france elle est une
puissance européenne est une puissance
mondiale
deuxièmement et surtout je considère que
la proposition allemande et consiste à
faire un état fédéral européen qui
serait dominée par l'allemagne pourquoi
un état fédéral européen et pourquoi est
ce que ray en allemagne ben je vais vous
expliquer premièrement parce que dira la
monnaie unique que tu une machine à
transférer tous les pouvoirs financiers
économiques fiscaux à une autorité
unique finalement parce qu'il y aura les
majorités qualifiées il y aura plus de
droit de veto et parce que la commission
de bruxelles
la fameuse commission tous mes amis il
est très beau de dire ce soir que nous
on est bien d'accord à commercialiser la
commission de bruxelles deviendra ces
documents allemands qui le dis c'est pas
moi le gouvernement de l'europe
donc ça c'est parce qu'il s'est passé
mais c'est sûr que si on avait su que si
la recovery sera le gouvernement de la
commission de bruxelles deviendra un
gouvernement etc c'est ce que deviendra
le conseil alain duhamel le conseil
organe des 11e chambre gouvernement une
deuxième chambre et le parlement
européen deviendra le parlement le
parlement de l'europe c'est à dire que
c'est fini pour les gouvernements
nationaux c'est fini pour les parlements
nationaux on aura fini la boucle dans ce
que vous dites on sera ce sera à l'état
fédéral alors pourquoi être redynamisé
pourquoi de griller par l'allemagne
après je termine ma nos jours parce que
dominés par masse dès le deuxième point
le premier vous nous aviez expliqué que
ce n'est pas bon pour la france deuxième
dominée par la meilleure sur le premier
point
si c'était aussi simple que vous le
dites et notamment ce qui concerne la
monnaie commune pourquoi est ce que en
allemagne y compris parmi les partisans
d'helmut kohl temps d'allemands
craindrait que ça soit comme ils le
disent comme l'écrivent au détriment du
marque parce que simple beaucoup
d'allemands ce qu'est ce que voit une
moue de colleville se dit moi je me sers
des institutions européennes pour
installer l'hégémonie allemande aux
roses a le droit
c'est ce qui se dit c'est ce qui se dit
sûr qu'il instrumentalise les
institutions européennes pour retrouver
l'hégémonie s'affirmant comme vous êtes
vous disiez tout à l'heure qu'il faut
être sincère qu'on se regarde bien dans
les yeux tout à fait un café alors moi
je suis sincère je regarde bien dans les
yeux à cordes
alors regardons bougez vous regarde
volontiers dans les yeux helmut kohl dit
que ce qu'il cherche à faire c'est
d'installer l'hégémonie allemande sur
l'europe à ce qu'ils disent à ce qu'il
lui arrive il se dit cela ainsi que
beaucoup d'allemands aujourd'hui qui
considère que s'il y a une europe
intégrée supra nationales et fédérales
c'est tout bon pour l'allemagne enfin
pour ne pas le voir il faut s'appeler
monsieur bourlanges aujourd'hui alors
monsieur pour langil faut vous rappeler
que c'est un des plus brillants député
européen français oui d'accord et qui si
elle vous ne diabolisez pas non non
simplement il siège au parti populaire
européen parti populaire européen c'est
le parti de démocrates de serpillière
européens dont le premier round y
compris de la part de monsieur
boulangeât était d'élire à la tête du
parlement européen un président allemand
et ça c'est pas bien une coïncidence
bon alors deux questions la deuxième
question dominé par l'allemagne où il
dominé par l'allemagne
oui parce que la monnaie unique vous
savez ce sera un marc déguisé qu'est ce
que les allemands sont tellement
réticences il c'est un marc déguisé même
façon quoi si la monnaie unique parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'allemands qui
considèrent regardons ce qui est
regardée constatant ce qu'il voit
actuellement par exemple en italie dans
l'idée ou dans l'europe du sud que cette
europe là ce sera une machine folle etc
à vouloir mutiler les souverainetés on
retrouvera hélas en allemagne en france
ou ailleurs ce qu'on est en train de
connaître en autriche ou en belgique
mais et c'est ce que me disait très bien
jimmy goldsmith justement encore hier
avant de partir en angleterre et des
séquences incroyables maastricht aura
détruit l'europe serre que maastricht
c'est une machine à déclencher des
forces centrifuges
mais alors leader néonazi il ya les
chiens il a il a profité du de cette
espèce de carcan dans lequel on nous
enferme pour faire un combat au nom de
l'identité de l'eau y est riche et
servier passent comme c'est au coeur de
votre raisonnement
comment est-ce qu'on peut à la fois dire
que s'il y avait une monnaie unique
ça serait une désintégration des
monnaies nationales et dire en même
temps et ça serait le triomphe du marx
et là où c'est l'autre ça peut paraître
les deux dangers en même temps comme un
saint il est évident que les allemands
ne lâcheront
le marque que si l'on à la place du
marque une monnaie qui soit un marc
améliorée vous savez vous sera la banque
centrale elle sera pas à paris sera pas
à londres sa part sera à classer comme
si on disait monsieur de vieux bonne
forme non mais vous êtes de bandes
noires c'est comme regarder aujourd'hui
francs on dit le ferrand et fort le
franc est fort à francfort où on voit
bien aujourd'hui que la monnaie unique
sera alors salle à francfort à tourner
mais j'aurais choisi le nom mais parce
qu'officiellement la monnaie commune moi
je suis pour la monnaie commune qu'est
ce que ça veut dire la monnaie commune
ça veut dire la concurrence des monnaies
y'a rien de tel que la concurrence des
monnaies pour être des indicateurs sur
la santé économique respectif de
différents pays
alors oui à la monnaie commune les q1
alors et dans laquelle jacques voisin et
convertibles une question parce que je
finissais je le regrette mais une
question est-ce que vous pensez que
puisqu'il ya l'élargissement qui se fait
les autrichiens ont déjà voté le oui les
finlandais la semaine dernière dont le
suédois vont voter dans trois semaines
ils vont peut-être le faire aussi est ce
que vous pensez qu'il faut modifier les
institutions en substance et si oui
comment
oui il faut les modifier il faut une
nouvelle définition
je dirais géographique de l'europe ce
que l'europe délie altas est finie
l'europe de maastricht c'est fini
maintenant faut faire l'europe de demain
l'europe de demain c'est celle qu'elle
la géographie rencontre l'histoire c'est
la grande europe avec des paliers les
uns c'est la grande europe de
l'institution les institutions
deuxièmement les institutions il faut
une europe des nations qui ne mutile par
les souverainetés et donc une europe
confédérale et non pas une europe
fédérale c'est un peu technique par des
venir et je vais vite concret
troisièmement et et troisièmement une
europe fondée sur la préférence
communautaire c'est-à-dire une union
douanière qu'est ce qu'on a fait en 1957
françois guyot on a fait un marché
commun c'est-à-dire un grand marché
libre à l'intérieur protégé avec six
malheureux pays et est protégée à
l'extérieur
or il n'est pas possible qu'on continue
à avoir une europe qui est une europe
libre échangiste une europe ouverte
saviez que les échelons je connaissais
vous connaissez très bien ces sujets
quant aux enchères j'espère au moment où
on a fait un match qu'on n'ait pas plus
ce moment on a fait le marché commun on
a également diminué les droits de douane
vis-à-vis du monde extérieur et on s'en
est pas si mal porté à l'époque oui mais
parce qu'à l'époque cela est ce que je
dis mais pas ce que lisbonne ne relance
pas parce que nous n'étions pas dans un
monde où du fait des nouvelles
technologies de la liberté des capitaux
commencé par faire tourner ce qui s'est
passé dans le dernier mois hewlett
packard boeing
et d'autres grandes entreprises
américaines comme ibm ou c'est ce qu'ils
ont fait ils ont décidé de transférer
sert de déménager leur production leurs
usines sont des grandes entreprises
multinationales y compris européens dans
les pays à bas salaires c'est-à-dire en
inde en a l'air du siden-sian bien la
mère selon bercy
alain duhamel donnez moi je reste merci
non non non monsieur vous allez être
coupé vous allez être coupée à la clé on
recense de la france un grand pays qui
va bien c'était à l'heure de vérité de
monsieur philippe de villiers président
virtuel du futur mpf des mois je le
suppose le mouvement pour la france
rediffusion cette nuit sur france 2 vers
1h10 et de maladies à 11h sur tv5 europe
bonne semaine à tous et à dimanche
prochain
[Musique]